we're just about to get our first
pictures from inside the courtroom with
normal average human lawyers and we'd
like to ah
ladies and gentlemen we've just lost the
picture but what we've seen speaks for
itself the courtroom has apparently been
taken over conquered if you will by a
master race of robot lawyers it's
difficult to tell from this Vantage
Point whether they will arbitrate the
captive Earth men or merely sue them
into submission but one thing is for
certain there is no stopping them the
autonomous attorneys will soon be here
and I for one welcome our new robot
lawyer overlords and I'd like to remind
them that as a trusted YouTube
personality I can be helpful in rounding
up other human lawyers to toil in their
underground legal data centers robots
are coming to replace all of the lawyers
wait why are you clapping last week
Humanity took one step closer to
embracing our robot overlords when Tech
wonderkid Joshua Browder offered a one
million dollar bounty to any lawyer
willing to let his AI chatbot argue a
case before the supreme court on January
8th Browder tweeted quote do not pay
will pay any lawyer or person one
million dollars with an upcoming case in
front of the United States Supreme Court
to wear air pods and let our robot
lawyer argue the case by repeating
exactly what it says we are making this
serious offer contingent on us coming to
a formal agreement and all rules being
followed please contact me if interested
router was undeterred by the horde of
actual lawyers pointing out that this
would violate the high courts Ironclad
ban on laptops cameras video recorders
cell phones tablets smart watches or any
electronic device of any kind in the
chamber Mr McGill you are warned to
leave your electronics outside and in a
follow-up tweet he scoffed oh yes how
could I forget about the airpods
security checkpoint making clear that
the 26 year old CEO had never set foot
inside the Supreme Court which screens
all entrants and is staffed by deputies
who would gladly tackle anyone stupid
enough to violate the ban on
transmitting audio of the ongoing
argument doesn't exactly bode well when
the CEO of an AI law company uh doesn't
know the first thing about the law yeah
I am not particularly worried about AI
replacing lawyers anytime soon so how
did we get here well it seems that the
teenage Joshua Browder was a bad driver
a very bad driver and even worse than
his driving in Joshua could not for the
life of him Park his car then he made
the shocking discovery that quote the
government issues tickets to make money
not necessarily to punish people so
Browder did what any normal kid would do
he wrote a chatbot to contest his
parking tickets online and in no time he
was lending the tool out to his friends
who were apparently also unable to
decipher street signs or maneuver their
cars within 18 inches of the curb and in
2015 when he was an 18 year old student
at Stanford University broader launched
the company do not pay from his dorm
room reportedly writing the code in
under two weeks working between the
hours of midnight and 3am and in no time
Silicon Valley was calling with generous
offers to buy it later he spent time as
a fellow in a program founded by venture
capitalist and Silicon Valley Visionary
Peter Thiel which pays students to drop
out of college and spend two years
building their companies on the theory
that quote some ideas can't wait records
show that at the time teal had one
thousand dollars in outstanding parking
tickets and a court date coming up soon
and while the bot was originally
programmed to contest parking tickets in
the UK and New York browder's company
soon expanded to include a host of
services using Tech spots and artificial
intelligence if you want to cancel your
gym membership or apply for a fishing
license or schedule an appointment at
the DMV there's a bot for that maybe you
want to fly with your emotional support
animal or close a bank account maybe you
want to marry an inmate in the county
jail maybe you're a Disney Super Fan and
you get your kick snitching on the
company when someone on Etsy makes a
Donald Duck tote bag hey man whatever
you're into what could possibly go wrong
but as you might surmise there are some
huge huge problems with this for a
monthly subscription of about twelve
dollars you too could use browder's Bots
to report a pothole to your local
government automatically cancel a
subscription at the end of your free
trial or appeal your property tax bill
tasks which you really shouldn't do
yourself without the supervision of a
parent or Guardian but if all this
company was offering was a computer
program which demands to speak to the
manager basically karenbot then we
probably wouldn't be talking about it
here today but do not pay hosts a bunch
of other applications some of which at
least skirt the line of practicing law
without a license because advising
someone on how to file a Freedom of
Information Act request or even a
complaint to the Securities Exchange
Commission is probably okay but
instructing someone on how to file for
divorce execute a power of attorney or
craft a cease and desist letter is a
much much dicier proposition and this
was clearly apparent to the lawyers who
drafted the site's terms of service
which remind customers over several
pages that do not pay is not a law firm
but rather a quote platform for Legal
Information and self-help but that
message is rather undercut by router's
own publicity in which he says that he
hopes to be like the general counsel for
the consumer and promises that the site
will quote make take the 200 billion
dollar legal profession free for
consumers uh I am not quaking in my
shorts right now now the website
LegalZoom which offers users to
customize legal documents to suit their
specific needs had a similar problem and
engaged in protracted litigation with
the state of North Carolina to ensure
that it did not run afoul of the state's
ban on the unauthorized practice of law
but his CEO wasn't making videos in
which he promised that the service would
quote find a loophole insert that
loophole into a legal letter and then
send that off to the right place or even
upload it to websites and have a robot
do all the clicking on your behalf it's
a bit difficult to maintain the fiction
that you're not practicing law when your
site builds itself as the world's first
robot lawyer but does this story sound
familiar to anyone else Stanford
University precocious genius beloved by
Silicon Valley aiming to revolutionize
an industry they never actually worked
in despite experts in the field telling
them in no uncertain terms that their
projects would not work yes he seemed
seems to be the latest technocrat who
has no idea what he's talking about
trying to propose technological
solutions to non-technological problems
Browder says that he couldn't afford to
pay these tickets as a young person so I
became a legal expert about all the
reasons why people could get out of
parking tickets really it's also of note
that Joshua browder's Father Bill
Browder is a wildly successful hedge
fund manager who championed the global
magnitsky act to sanction Russian
authorities after they arrested
accountant Sergey magnitsky and left him
to die in prison without medical care
for exposing State corruption but Rich
nerd who didn't feel like paying his
parking fines and dummied up a bot to
contest them is a lot less compelling
origin story than broke student
ingeniously beats the system so here we
are but with crypto being hammered and
AI becoming the new web 3 let's count
all the ways that this actually won't
work to begin with Browder seems a
little fuzzy on what lawyers do all day
lawyers are charging hundreds of dollars
an hour for copying and pasting a few
documents presumably the late Sergey
bagnisky would probably disagree ditto
for the ones who fight to keep Josh's
Dad one step ahead of Russian Expedition
attempts but if your definition of legal
expertise is staring at the parking code
and parsing the semantics of street
signs then it's not surprising that you
might think a computer could easily
accomplish that with a few lines of code
and if you're willing to believe that a
bot is just as good at drafting legal
documents as someone who went through
years of formal education and then learn
their craft under experienced
practitioners then why wouldn't you
believe that artificial intelligence is
capable of arguing at the highest court
in the land but honestly that's sort of
par for the course among the Silicon
Valley Elite for example Elon musk's was
recently asked on the witness stand why
he believed that the contract might not
apply to him and he said quote I have
some familiarity with the legal system I
mean if you're in enough lawsuits you
pick up a few things along the way and
what Elon keeps showing us time and time
again is even if you are a really smart
person who built a great company you
don't know what you don't know and here
that seems to be a lot browder's plan
involves using open ai's chat gpt3 to
feed dialogue to quote any lawyer or
person with an upcoming case in front of
the United States Supreme Court
interesting that he thinks lawyer in
person are mutually exclusive although
he wants to replace us with Rosie for
The Jetsons so yeah I guess that
probably tracks actual lawyers the
humankind will tell you that the Supreme
Court is one of the most high-bound
institutions on Earth the justices had
to be dragged Kicking and Screaming into
the 21st century during covid when they
finally permitted simultaneous
transmission of oral arguments they plan
to allow cameras in the courtroom in the
year of Never So anyone attempting to
play ventriloquist dummy via earpiece is
likely to find himself in the custody of
the bailiff in pretty short order
moreover any attorney who committed to
turn the control of the case over to a
robot would leave that person open to a
charge of malpractice which they would
definitely lose while the person paying
the lawyer to do it might be charged
with the unauthorized practice of Law
and that's probably true for anyone
paying for a pro se litigant to let the
machine argue on their behalf as well
but even if this weren't illegal it's
worth noting that browder's plan relies
on a brand new off the rack technology
that is largely untested in the real
world and even so browder's proofs of
concept are decidedly mixed earlier this
month he posted a video to Twitter
claiming to show a chatbot using a deep
fake of his voice to successfully
negotiate with a representative from
Wells Fargo to secure a refund of wire
fees the video has since been removed
for violating Twitter's terms of service
and the bank claims that it was
deceptively edited anyway but even taken
at face value Vice reports that the
recording contained long pauses where
the bank employee waited patiently for
the chat program to formulate a response
and that's definitely not going to fly
in Court Justice uh
ah
objection plus it's pretty noticeable if
your plan is to insert this bot into an
actual hearing by stealth the technology
is probably not there yet although
lawyers are increasingly relying on
artificial intelligence to help them
sort through a mountain of documents to
find the ones that are relevant to their
cases a real world application that
Browder seems wholly uninterested in
since it doesn't involve blowing up an
entire industry AI is definitely helping
with the practice of law just not
without the humans they seem to be
pretty necessary and browder's other big
success involved letting the chatbot
engage in a very stilted negotiation
with a Comcast agent or possibly one of
Comcast's own chat Bots to reduce an
engineer's Bill how did it do this well
it used a mix of neural networks hidden
Markov models and lying quote the AI
just exaggerated the Internet outages
similar to how a customer would
that he then acknowledged that the tool
was quote not perfect yet and promised
to quote sterilize outputs before launch
this touches on another problem with his
genius plan to unleash this program on
the Supreme Court the Bots lie in fact
chat gpt's propensity to make up things
that sound true uh releasing a stream of
quote fluent BS got it temporarily
banned from message boards on the coding
site stack Overflow and the line between
fluent BS and sanctionable lack of
Candor before a tribunal is not one that
you want to find yourself on the wrong
side of Browder himself acknowledged
this limitation in a conversation with
Politico but assured reporters that his
company had gone to Great Lengths to
ensure that the bot will be as honest as
George Washington in open court and if
you can't trust a guy who programs deep
fakes to impersonate himself online I
mean who can't you trust and in response
to the potential illegality Browder told
Gizmodo that he might rely on
accommodations for people who are deaf
or hard of hearing to smuggle the
earpiece into a hearing but no fear
according to Politico browder's company
will soon test the bot out in real Court
somewhere he claims to have discovered
two jurisdictions where his hair brain
scheme is quote not outright illegal
although he's not saying where lest the
courts in question find out and decide
that actually it is illegal after all
though I'm not sure that I would rely on
his understanding of what is legal and
illegal in parsing the local rules of
different courts but in one hearing the
defendant will head into court with a
recording device and earbuds
transmitting the hearing live and
repeating whatever the AI Whispers into
his ear the other is a traffic court
being conducted via Zoom which shouldn't
be that difficult except that Browder is
toying with the idea of having the AI
clone the defendant's voice and speak
the words itself I like your funny words
Magic Man although he admits the quote
that could get us into a lot of trouble
and as Browner sees it his trouble Road
testing the technology is all part of a
plot by the legal professions who
preserve its Stranglehold on the
marketplace and hold off the market
progress quote there's all these
Gatekeepers there's laws there's
governments to work around yeah a
profession that requires you to pass the
bar in every single legal jurisdiction
in the United States I can't imagine
that the lawyers would want to keep a
monopoly on all of this profession and
if you were wondering what services do
not pay actually offers to people right
now well thankfully paralegal
extraordinary Catherine Tucson has
already gone through a lot of the
services that the website offers she has
a patients that I simply don't have
signed up for an accountant went through
what they offer and do not pay seems to
offer a whole bunch of services that
really really seem like the practice of
law including being able to sue anyone
in small claims court and divorce
divorce settlement agreements Catherine
went through the process of creating a
demand letter connected to a small
claims court filled in the information
and found that basically it's just a
service that puts in the information
that you provide into a form it doesn't
seem to offer anything related to AI at
the moment and there's no option to use
the real-time AI lawyer services either
the end result is a demand letter that
is basically worse than nothing that is
sort of nonsense doesn't really further
the ball and it really demonstrates why
you want a lawyer to draft these things
the service doesn't seem to do any
actual legal analysis and seems to
encourage you to file a claim in small
claims court that is actually too big to
file in small claims court and it's not
entirely clear but although this claims
to be an AI company there seems to be a
lot of human intervention in all of
these different results which is not
great when you're doing things that may
actually qualify as the practice of Law
and you know the humans might have some
liability for that offense but look this
might be hard to understand for people
that don't actually practice law but
practicing law is more than just
arranging magic words in the right order
while trying to sound human lawyers get
paid to exercise their judgment you hire
a lawyer because you know that he or she
understands divorce law better than you
do they can draft a business partnership
that accomplishes what you want they've
been around the courthouse long enough
that you're better off taking the plea
agreement and unlike Joshua Browder they
can actually read the room and if
something goes wrong and they give you
bad advice then you can sue your lawyer
for malpractice so maybe you'll be fine
if you represent yourself in traffic
court or even if you let a chatbot
whiskey spur into your ear during a
traffic hearing but when the cost of
getting it wrong is high like it might
be if you're in the Supreme Court a
human lawyer is worth the money and a
very tiny number of lawyers will spend
their entire careers honing their craft
to be good enough to argue before The
Supreme Court and they're not about to
be replaced by a chat bot that can
barely negotiate with a customer service
agent so someone tells you that they've
got a robot that can feed you lines in
court or God forbid clone your voice and
speak for you maybe tell them to go away
and come back when they've mastered
parallel parking and hello this is Devin
from the future and I'm happy to report
we got them boys uh because Joshua
Browder is reporting that after being
threatened by state prosecutors for the
unlawful practice of Law and violating
all kinds of Court restrictions he's
going to back down and he's not moving
forward with having an AI actually
whisper into someone's ear in even
traffic court and they're actually
removing a lot of the services that do
not pay currently offers that look like
legal practice so from the public
backlash and the criticism it looks like
they are doing the right thing not
offering legal services that could have
a dramatically bad effect on people and
focusing on consumer related things
rather than the practice of law so
although the lawyers weren't exactly
holding their breath on this they can
breathe a tiny sigh of relief that at
least people are not going to be harmed
by the negligent practice of law at the
helm of an AI chatbot but there's still
a lot out there on the internet that can
hurt you which is where today's sponsor
nordvpn comes in because you know that
incognito mode isn't actually Incognito
right with nordvpn's no logs policy your
internet service provider doesn't get to
Snoop on what you're searching and
neither does nordvpn and Nord is more
than just a VPN it comes with a whole
Suite of threat protection tools for
example if you follow some of your
favorite creators on social media you
might have heard stories of a channel
getting hacked basically a Creator
losing access after a successful
attacker password is leaked Alex's
Corner one of our nebula friends
recently got their Channel stolen and
turned into a repository for
cryptocurrency scam nordvpn's threat
protection includes specific features to
warn you about fishing links as well as
features like a blocker for malicious
ads and dark web monitoring to alert you
if your passwords have been leaked and
of course nordvpn is a great VPN with
Nord you can surf the web anonymously
and your location stays safe it allows
me to set my location all over the world
which lets me access different versions
of my favorite websites and when I'm out
of the country and try to connect to
Gmail or a bunch of other things that
I'm logged into all those accounts would
normally freak out and tell me that I'm
being hacked so now I just reroute my
connection to the US and my Gmail and
everything else works perfectly like it
always does so if you'd like to give
nordvpn a try click on the link that's
on screen right now or down in the
description to get an additional one
month free with a huge discount and it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee so click on the
link below to get one month free with a
huge discount with a free 30-day
money-back guarantee and after that
click on this box over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court